hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today's could be something a
little bit different I remember I did
this like months and months ago but I
haven't done it in a very long time but
these are just some stream highlights
that I've taken from my stream you guys
want to know what my twitch is this down
in the description it's twitch.tv slash
extra gyt
hopefully twitch gets back to me so we
can get rid of that name and just make
it clearly gingy that'd be super dope
but I gotta wait for them to get back to
me on the support ticket but yeah if you
guys want to come onto my streams i
stream roughly about three to four times
a week I'm gonna start doing that a lot
more yeah would that enjoy some of the
highlights and I'll see you guys later I
can't want to purchase tea on DS
execution to go better like just a BM
some kid we're gonna buy C on DS
execution I'm not ending the stream
until I completely destroy somebody's
whole integrity with T on D let's go now
we're gonna do it we're gonna disrespect
the [ __ ] out of them this better be the
same one that ruined it cuz he's gonna
odd look at the warlord look at that
warlord T magnet is perfect
what you know about playing C on D
brother
oh my god what have what is happening
through what just happened what just
happened dude
this whole it's bit this has basically
been a sellout stream not even getting
money from it but just the the the
things I've said this stream have just
been completely sellout what awful what
Dolph [ __ ] was that oh I did the drop
shot has a nasty execution if I can
remember correctly yeah it's still buzz
bye-bye that's so pretty dude
you will either get it tomorrow
according to the website or after this
whole thing is over like on the 8th like
on the it because this ends August 7th
so most likely you'll get this August
8th this is gonna hurt but um but you
will you will get the rewards
hundred-percent
no if you go can get away from me
oh dude let's [ __ ] go baby do you see
my health do you see that dude holy [ __ ]
again dude well I I'm giving him revenge
on purpose though like as a joke but
this is really dragging out longer than
it should right now oh [ __ ] I would
definitely say I'm a bit better than at
apex important I this [ __ ] guy
okay buddy you
oh man that needs to be clipped
immediately a crow Jiro Meister twizzler
t-bone Ober
he needs some milky milk that's the best
name I've heard all day you late to an
hour and you will get the our award you
don't have to watch me you don't have to
watch me for 24 hours straight and you
don't have to watch me for the full 24
hours nope
oh my god dude please oh my god please
click that did my heart sank into my ass
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
yay oh my
oh do we so can beat this we could so
win this game we just don't even have to
move oh this is ballsy oh oh my god
the the cojones bro the cojones on me
right now that was so goddamn risky like
we have to stream for so our viewers can
get it and then we got to watch it
ourselves so like the streamers are
helping out the streamers what was that
oh my god yo can somebody please click
that dude that was the sky that was
stupid
[Music]
you